what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the mcu sorry for the short
video today but i am a little bit sick
however we do have some really exciting
news because it looks like we could be
getting a few new trailers for marvel
studios projects if not a few at least
one and we're thinking that this one
could be for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness we have the teaser
trailer that came out as the second
post-credit of spider-man no way home
which they quickly released not too long
after that but we don't have the
official trailer for doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness yet just the
teaser but it could be coming soon along
with possibly another trailer for moon
knight the official trailer for that and
not just the teaser and maybe an
official teaser for miss marvel and
possibly she-hulk so if you want to stay
up to date on everything be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
now the super bowl is coming up on
sunday february 13th and for the true
marvel fans you know that marvel usually
releases one if not a couple or a few
teasers or full trailers during the
super bowl now marvel has kind of gone
back and forth whether they do one
whether they do two it kind of just
depends on what all is happening but
right now rumor has it that we could be
getting the official trailer for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
this isn't confirmed in any way but it
does make sense it's the next big marvel
movie coming to theaters and it is a big
movie the multiverse of madness could
change the mcu forever it could bring
old characters in new characters and we
could see some unexpected cameos some
characters that have died could return
as variants of course but nonetheless
this movie is going to be absolutely
huge and if you want a lot of people to
know about it and get excited about it
you show it during the super bowl now at
the same time last year during the super
bowl marvel did take the opportunity to
show a trailer for the falcon and the
winter soldier so this year they might
take that same opportunity to try and
promote some upcoming disney plus shows
like moon night she-hulk or miss marvel
technically we have seen teasers for
hulk and miss marvel they just aren't
the official teasers we've seen footage
that disney put out on disney plus day
but this means that the teasers for miss
marvel and she-hulk are most likely done
and there is a possibility that we could
be getting those teasers during the
super bowl now marvel isn't about to
drop four different trailers during the
super bowl at least i don't think they
could but i don't think so but since the
two upcoming projects are multiverse of
madness and moon knight i'm assuming
that we're going to get either one of
them or both of them during the super
bowl and marvel hasn't missed a super
bowl spot in years they've had something
every year so no matter what we are
going to be getting something now as far
as what time we are not sure like i said
sunday february 13th the day of the
super bowl it could be any time it could
be in the beginning it could be during
halftime it could be towards the end but
no matter what happens marvel studios
will upload it to youtube immediately
after so if you're not trying to watch
the super bowl the entire time you can
just have your notifications on for
marvel and myself because i'll be
posting it immediately as it comes out
in the meantime let me know what you are
most excited for would you like to see
dr strange in the multiverse of madness
moon knight she-hulk or miss marvel let
me know which you'd like to see in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all things mcu for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof